Toronto. There's another great city that starts with a T. Tampa, Florida. Fly to Tampa on Porter Airlines to see why it's so tea-riffic. On your way there, relax with free beer, wine and snacks. Free fast streaming Wi-Fi and no middle seats. You've never flown to Florida like this before, so you'll land in Tampa ready to explore. Visit flyporter.com and actually enjoy economy.
Interior Chinatown is an all-new series based on the best-selling novel by Charles Yu about a struggling Asian actor who gets a bigger part than he expected when he witnesses a crime in Chinatown. Streaming November 19, only on Disney+. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you.
Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind-the-scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hey there. Are you ready to break down The Office webisodes, the accountants?
I'm so ready. I loved rewatching these. It was so fun. I texted Brian Baumgartner this morning and I said Brian, watching these webisodes is making me miss you so much buddy. We just had such a good time and of course Oscar too and the three of us have got to get together. We have our accountant's dinner you know. Yeah. So we've got to get it back on the books. Well these were written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Schur and they were directed by
Randall Einhorn. This was his directorial debut. Yes, it was so exciting. I'm going to give you a summary. Do it. The accountants discover that there is $3,000 missing from the company money. Everyone is a suspect as they interrogate their co-workers to find the missing funds. Everyone is on Angela's list. Well, not everyone. Well, not Roy or Dwight. There's two missing.
Guess what? I'm going to give you three fast facts today. It's a rewatch breakdown. I can't get rid of them. I'm trying so hard. They will not die. Just lean into the s*** you love, lady. Alright, fast fact number one. The Accountants' Webisodes were originally released on July 13th, 2016 between seasons two and seasons three on NBC.com. This was their way of keeping office viewers engaged over the summer hiatus. They were 10 mini episodes. Each one is about two or three minutes in length. On July 13th, they released the first two on the same day. But then they spaced them out.
You had to wait to see the next ones. You can currently see them on YouTube and also as a special feature on the season two DVD. Yes, it's disc four, everybody. And they're on Peacock as well. Well, The Accountants was the first series of webisodes. We end up doing more of these in the future. But these were the first.
They were groundbreaking. I'm going to get into that a little more in Fast Fact number three. But Angela, we had some fan questions for you. OK. The first one is from Amanda G. in Northern Ireland, who said, how did these episodes come about? And we also heard from Bria D. and Philly who said, what was your reaction to finding
out you guys were going to do these webisodes? I remember they reached out to us and I don't know if they reached out to everyone, but I know they reached out to me and Brian and Oscar, and they were talking about doing these little things for NBC.com. So I remember talking to the folks in the digital department and they were saying, you know, we think this would be really fun to do. And I was like, sure, great.
And I was also very excited to have a bigger storyline with the accountants. Yeah. You know, we had our running joke, right? That we would do all these bits in the corner, they would never make it in. And I know I've talked about this, that we sort of joked that we had a spinoff,
but it was on Telemundo, and Oscar said it was called Los Acantadores, Angela, Oscar, eat K-been. So now here we finally get to have a whole episode, sort of, right, about the accountants. Okay, are you ready for fast fact number two? I am. This is a fan question from Sarah M. in Pennsylvania who said, were the webisodes filmed on the same day as other episodes or did the cast come in specifically to film them?
Well, Sarah, guess who I reached out to? The last from the past, Kentopedia. Kentopedia, and then you also reached out to Angelopedia. I did. Let me tell you what I found out, because Kent explained a little bit about how these were produced from his point of view, and I'm sure you can confirm a lot of these details, Angela.
He said, y'all came in on a hiatus week. Yeah. It was in March. It took two days to film all 10 webisodes and that they were filmed on March 2nd and March 3rd. Yes, and those were our days off. So when we came to set that day, there was no one there. It was kind of wild. It was like when you go like to school, like after school extracurriculars,
and there's like no one in the building. Oh, yeah. I saw like the crew call sheet. Very small crew. In fact, not only was Randall Einhorn the director of this episode, but he was also the cinematographer and the camera operator, and there was only one camera. Is that true? That's true. Randall did all of that, and then we had one sound person. It was Ben Patrick.
I saw that too. Yep, and they were on stage with us, but that was pretty much it. Well, here are the actors who were there both days. It was you, Oscar, Brian, Kate, Phyllis, and Leslie. Mm-hmm. And I really noticed when I was rewatching these how Randall had to get very creative in how he shot things to avoid showing how empty the desks were in the bullpen because the whole cast was not there. Yes you're gonna see a point of view from the camera that you do not see on the show
that airs every week. And I loved seeing it. I love seeing this different perspective of the office. I felt like there were so many angles that we did not normally see on the office. I got very interested in tracking how Randall was able to shoot things without seeing through certain windows or into the bullpen. And also I was tracking how exactly he used Leslie, Kate and Phyllis in the background of things. Strategically.
Yes. Well, I texted Randall and I said, Randall, I don't know if I ever thanked you for what a wonderful gift it was getting to do these webisodes because it was such a big deal to us. And he made it so fun and it looks fantastic. And I really think they hold up. Well, we got this fan question for you, Angela. And it's kind of about the process of filming. It's from Ryan T. in Aston, Pennsylvania,
who said, Angela, what was your favorite part of filming this series and how was it different from filming the actual show? I guess maybe besides the very small crew. Was there anything else? I just loved getting to have a whole day with Oscar and Brian. We had so many silly bits that we had made up already those few seasons together, like our little accounting dynamics that we would play out that rarely made it to the light of day, but we were doing them in the background, you know?
And just to have a day where we showed up and we got to just play all day together, it was the best. And I feel like when I rewatched it, I was remembering so many things I'm excited to share with you guys. All right, are you ready for Fast Fact number three? I am.
Fast Fact number three is called Very Successful. It was. These webisodes received millions of views on NBC.com. They broke the mold. They invented, in many ways, this idea of supplemental content for streaming or for websites. Yes. I had been emailing Joya Balfour, who helped us so much.
She worked for NBC Digital. And she said the accountants was really when NBC saw that digital content for the office had a ton of potential. It's not just NBC that realized it. Kent said that after the success of the webisodes, he was contacted by almost every production executive from every studio asking how we did it. Wow. But not only that, the webisodes won two awards. They won a Webby Award for video comedy short form and an Emmy for outstanding broadband program comedy. Angela, what was that experience like? You won an Emmy.
I know. Well, I thought to really have that experience, we should have the Emmy here with us today. What? You brought it? Oh, my gosh. I see this in your house all the time. And I, oh, my gosh.
I love it, lady. It's very large. Wow. Oh my gosh, I love it lady. It's very large. Wow. That is so awesome. There you go. Can I see it? I wanna hold it. Yeah, watch out though.
The wings are really pointy. They're very pointy. Well, the only time I got to hold an Emmy was when our show won an Emmy in season two. I did not get to keep it. I got to hold an Emmy was when our show won an Emmy in season two. I did not get to keep it. I got to hold it for the pictures and then give it back. And it has your name on it. I know.
Mm-hmm. That is f***ing rad. Well, I thought I would read to you what it says on my Emmy. Yes. It says 2006 to 2007 Daytime Entertainment Emmy Awards, Outstanding Broadband Program Comedy, The Office, Accountants, NBC, Angela Kinsey, Performer. So freaking cool. Oh, it's heavy.
So who all was at the ceremony? Who'd you get to celebrate with? Was Randall there? What was that night like? Well, first of all, we couldn't believe we had been nominated for an Emmy for the webisodes. We didn't even know there was a category for that. I mean, we really were so just surprised and excited
just because they were nominated. And I remember we went, a big group of us went with the NBC digital team and none of us were prepared to give a speech. None of us wrote anything. We didn't think we would win. We just were so excited to go. And lady, I do have a journal entry. I wrote in my journal about my outfit for the night. Would you really hear it? Of course I would. Yes, I wrote in my journal, Sam, you're going to love this. Ready? Okay. I found a dress for the daytime Emmys exclamation point. Woohoo! Exclamation point. And it doesn't need to
be altered. Double woohoo. I got it at Arden B in the mall it's a black and white beaded mini dress I don't have shoes yet wish me luck with that who's it to my who my who's wishing me like this letter home or it's just your journal it's just my journal about it okay and I had a bunch I have a bunch of pictures so I have a bunch of stuff okay and then I said also I wore a black and white. So I have a bunch of stuff. Okay. And then I said, also, I wore a black and white dress to the other Emmys last year. What's up with me in black and white dresses? Double, double question mark. Double question mark. We'll fill you in after. And then I never wrote again after you never let yourself know how it went.
We'll fill you in. Did you get shoes? I don't know. We don't know. I don't know. I don't know if I got shoes. But my dress was from Art and B in the mall. So when we won, we really were, it's like that moment, it sounds like a cliche where you're like, what?
I can't believe it. And the three of us went up, Brian, Oscar, and me, and I think we sort of stumbled through an acceptance speech. And then we went to this party afterwards. There was like a rooftop patio, and we took a bunch of press pictures, Jenna, and all of the pictures,
even with the big group, with the big team of NBC Digital. I'm holding the Emmy. I'm always the one holding the Emmy. I'm like, did I not let anyone else hold it? And at one, I lifted high over my head and I thought, oh no, please don't take anyone out. Like I did with Phyllis and Steve's Golden Globe. That's your favorite thing.
I guess it's knocking someone with a trophy. It was such, such a fun night. And I just remember it just being such a highlight of my time on the office. Well, you mentioned that we've been talking with Brian Baumgartner because he's gonna be a guest on an upcoming episode, but we ended up also chatting with him about the webisodes and he sent in an audio clip
of his memories of doing the webisodes and of that Emmy night. Let's listen. I remember that first webisode series, The Accountants, being so much fun. Angela and Oscar, of course, and I getting to really play for the first times and almost being stars of our own show there for a few days with the rest of the gang, mostly, mostly
gone. I remember having such a great time and when we eventually won the Emmy for that series, I remember that being one of the most fun nights. Angela Yu and Oscar and I having a party that night when we won the Emmy. Well, it's one of my favorite and most fondest memories of our outside life while we were filming the show. Aw, same. I have so many fun pictures from that night too
that I can share. That's when Jenna, I got bangs. Oh really? Yeah, I'm sure that's a journal entry. Don't look for her. That was a big swing for me, I got bangs. And did you guys also go to a ceremony when you won the Webby?
Well actually, I'm not sure why, but Brian and Oscar weren't able to go. I can't remember why, but I did. I went there with Joya from NBC Digital, and I accepted on behalf of the accountants. The Webby. Did you wear your same dress? I didn't, I wore a different dress.
I don't know, I don't have any journal entry about this dress, it's just a little black dress. And you know how at the Webby's, you can only say five words for your acceptance speech? Yes. You remember this because we won a Webby in 2022. The Office Ladies is a Webby's People's Voice winner in podcast, television, and film. Do you remember what our acceptance speech was? I believe it ended with that's what she said.
Yes, it did and I found it. But what was the first word? Here we are. Speechless. That's what she said. There it is. Well, I was curious. I was like, what did I say? What were my five words?
I couldn't remember and I knew it was like something about accounting and I reached out to Joya and she said, Angela, I remember I have it here. And she sent it to me. Our acceptance speech was, accounting is such a riot. and I reached out to Joya and she said, Angela, I remember, I have it here. And she sent it to me. Our acceptance speech was, accounting is such a riot. And I said it just like that with my snarky Angela Martin face. Amazing. So there you go.
Well, something I think we should share is that you all filmed these for free. Mike and Paul wrote these for free. Mike and Paul wrote these for free, and yes, you won two awards, but you have never received any compensation for these webisodes. And NBC continues to monetize them on YouTube and Peacock. You do not receive residuals on them.
And that is because this was what we were saying before. This was all new territory. It was originally seen as marketing and publicity for the show. But after their success, our unions, SAG and WGA, started to rethink how actors should be compensated for creating original content outside of the normal network broadcast.
I mean, the success of the webisodes really brought into focus all the ways that talent could become exploited if we didn't get some guardrails on this new medium. That's right. That's right. I think that's kind of a cool thing that our show did. Yeah, I do too. And you know, and we know, people think that we sit around collecting
like millions of dollars a year on residuals from the office. And we don't. No. We do not receive residuals on Peacock or Netflix or any of the streamers. We never have. And that is because all of our contracts predated streaming. It literally did not exist. There was no language in our unions or in our contracts for how we would be compensated for it.
Digital content was so new when we started the show. I mean, clearly it was brand new. Yes. Anyway, I would like to thank the webisodes for kicking off that conversation for Artists Everywhere. Aw, I love that. Well, Jenna, just to wrap this up really quickly before we get into the breakdown, if you'll notice I just brought in my Emmy. I didn't bring in the Webby.
Yeah. Because the Webby, I think, went to NBC Digital. Like, I didn't leave in the Webby. Yeah. Because the Webby, I think went to NBC Digital. Like I didn't leave New York with a Webby. Okay. But when we won this daytime Emmy, they handed us this one Emmy to hold as we did our- The photo op Emmy. The photo op Emmy.
And I just said, I'm gonna take it home. And they were like, what? And I was like, yeah, I'm gonna take it home and then you should send Brian an Oscar one too. And there was this look, there was this moment where they were like, that's not really your, and I was like, thank you, bye. Lady, I love that.
I love that you did that. You were like, I am not gonna walk up on an Emmy stage again. Because we didn't get one when we won the show. No, none of the performers got it. It went to the producers. Yeah, so I went home with the trophy. It had no writing on it.
And a few weeks later in the mail, I got the plaque that went around it. I don't think I was meant to get this to take home. I think it's supposed to be on a shelf somewhere at NBC. Well, it's not. It's on our podcasting table right now. And Brian and Oscar got one too. Well done. Well, those are our fast facts. Why don't we take a break and we will get into our
breakdown with episode number one, The Books Don't Balance. They all have titles. I love them all. I know, me too. This segment is brought to you by Macy's. Angela, do you know how Michael would always leave things to like the last minute? Like in healthcare, he waits until the last minute to pick a healthcare plan and he promises us a big surprise at the end of the day. But then all we get are some melted ice cream sandwiches. Exactly. Well, I do not want to be the Michael Scott of the holidays this year. That's a good play on.
I do not want to wait to the last minute and give lame gifts. No. In fact, I am really getting ahead this year. And thanks to Macy's early Black Friday deals, I am stocking up on gifts for everyone at really great prices. Well, you know I am too. You guys, Office Ladies is so excited to partner with Macy's this holiday.
The Macy's gift guide is amazing. Amazing. Amazing. So many great gift suggestions and we've even opened up our own Macy's storefront. It's so cute. We've picked some great gifts. We have wonderful suggestions for you for the holidays. So part of getting ready for the holidays is also getting myself ready. And Angela, you know me, at the holidays I have a stack of ugly Christmas sweaters. You do. That is my go-to. But this year I really wanted to up my holiday fashion game. You were very excited about this. I have a lot to celebrate this year and I wanted a little dazzle. I wanted a little something sophisticated and I found the coolest DKNY black sequined bomber jacket on Macy's.com. I just love it. I can
wear it with a sweater and then I put it with like this green satin button down. It was very Christmasy. I wore it to a bar mitzvah. I can wear it at New Year's. And lady, it's actually pretty warm. I mean, it's not for the snow or something, right? But it's perfect in the evenings, you know, when it gets chilly in California. Well, when you tried it on, I said,
lady, this is a showstopper. You look so kidnaped. It is a showstopper. And I think you can wear it like a blazer. Like, you can wear it inside. So I put it in our storefront. And you're also going to link to it in our Office Ladies Pod stories this week.
I am. You know, this time of year, I love a cozy bedroom. And Macy's has the softest bedding. It's just gonna make you wanna curl up and feel comfy and festive. I found this super soft warm bedding by Uggs. Oh, Uggs makes the best bedding lady. I had never heard of that.
I didn't even know they made bedding. Yes. So here's the deal. Macy's has several Ugg comforters. They're all so cozy I bought one for Josh and I's bed and now the kids want one too. They come in several colors You can have them for the holidays or year-round. I'm gonna put it in our storefront as well. I'll link to it in stories I'm just so happy about it
Because not only is it cozy, but it looks nice. Yeah, I mean Mm-hmm Macy's Black Friday deals are starting now. Shop early and score the best deals before they're gone. And if you need any help with your gift buying, check out our gift list. For example, if you have a coffee lover in your life, I recommend a Gooseneck kettle and a pour over coffee carafe. So check out our list and give love,
give a luxurious coffee experience. But that's just one idea, Ange. Macy's also has fantastic selections of gourmet foods and candies. I love these kind of gifts. They are perfect for your neighbors, that favorite teacher at your kid's school. I put their holiday jams from Stonewall Kitchen in our storefront because they're so festive and they're yummy. What a great gift. There really is something for everyone and every budget. We really do not want you to be Michael Scott this holiday season.
No, we do not. So go get your shopping done with Macy's this year, your one-stop shop for everything on your list. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop our favorites this holiday season directly from our gift guide storefront by visiting the link in our Instagram bio at Office Ladies Pod. Yes, that's Office Ladies Pod on Instagram and I'll put a link in our stories too. Here we go, episode one, the books don't balance. We open on Jan, Oscar, Angela, and Brian in the conference room.
Angela delivers the news that they've discovered about $3,000 missing. Jan suggests this might be an accounting error, and Angela's like, it is not an accounting error. It's not her accounting error at least. Don't bring that BS my way, Jan. She gives a little glare to Kevin and we cut to his talking head where he says, this is the first time hearing about it.
He's not heard of the accounting area. He says nobody ever tells him anything and he likes it that way. He likes it that way, although later we find out he's so excited to be a part of this. And angry that he's never allowed to write memos. Exactly. Jan says they need to find the missing money ASAP. You know, they wanna ensure
there's been no criminal activity. I have an improv moment for you. I bet I know what it is. When Angela says, Michael said to stop by on your way out. I knew it. You know my sort of improv voice now so well. Again, I strategically put it at the very end hoping it would make it. Well, Angela, you just made someone very happy. We got a fan letter from Maria F. in Brazil who wanted to know if there were any jokes or scenes that were improvised or if it was all scripted.
And Maria also said, I really love the office. Angela is my favorite character. Oh, Maria, thank you. Big hugs to Brazil. I'm loving it. Well, Maria, here's the thing. These were written really well, but we did have little moments
and I'll share those with you as we go. But the thing I also love is that when I improvised that line, Melora as Jan's reaction was so perfect. I knew I was setting her up for a great reaction and that's always fun to do. I thought the other brilliant thing about it, Ange, was that you were also setting up the world beyond the conference room. I mean, you knew it was empty out there. Oh yeah. But you were filling it in. It was nice to imagine that Michael was in his office. Oh yeah. Thank you.
Mm-hmm. Well Oscar's gonna have a talking head where he said it's probably Michael because every time money has gone missing it's been Michael's fault. I love that he says he goes out with like clients for lunch and then it's a $50 receipt to J.Crew. I'm surprised to find out that Michael shops at J. Crew. Oh, that is true. Oscar and Angela both say, you know, listen, we've gone over our books so many times. There's not an accounting error.
And then Kevin says, well, I wonder if anyone bought anything really nice recently. And then Angela's so snarky. She looks at Oscar and goes, nice watch, Oscar, where'd that come from? And he's like, you know what, from my grandfather. He gave it to me when he died and she said, well I haven't seen it before, he must have died recently. I know, that's so mean.
I know and he's like, he did three weeks ago. Good Angela. Okay, I have another improv moment for you. Okay. When Kevin sympathetically reaches across the table to hold Oscar's hand, that was not scripted. Brian improvised that. It was a nice touch. Wasn't it? I love that these little webisodes each have a button on the end. All right, webisode number two. This one is titled Phyllis. In their search for the missing $3,000, the accountants are going to meet with Phyllis. Angela has a talking head where $3,000, the accountants are going to meet with Phyllis. Angela has a talking head where she says, Michael is the obvious suspect, but since
I know and he's like, he did three weeks ago. Good Angela. Okay, I have another improv moment for you. Okay. When Kevin sympathetically reaches across the table to hold Oscar's hand, that was not scripted. Brian improvised that. It was a nice touch. Wasn't it? I love that these little webisodes each have a button on the end. All right, webisode number two. This one is titled Phyllis. In their search for the missing $3,000, the accountants are going to meet with Phyllis. Angela has a talking head where $3,000, the accountants are going to meet with Phyllis. Angela has a talking head where
he's the boss, they have to at least pretend to look at other people first. This begins the recap nature of the webisodes. You will notice, even though they all flow together, they also still had to stand alone, which meant every episode, someone had to recap the plot. Someone had to tell us. $3,000 is missing. And everyone is a suspect. In this one, it was your job, Ange.
she says, Michael is the obvious suspect, but since he's the boss, they have to at least pretend to look at other people first. This begins the recap nature of the webisodes. You will notice, even though they all flow together, they also still had to stand alone, which meant every episode, someone had to recap the plot. Someone had to tell us. $3,000 is missing. And everyone is a suspect. In this one, it was your job, Ange.
Well Oscar's going to ask Phyllis if she bought anything with company money, and she looks down guilty. Angela's like, I knew it. Phyllis explains that she broke the heel on her shoe while at a corporate sales call. I just loved that backstory. I just loved it and she used the company card. She apologizes, it was $14.
And then what happens next to me, it's only 20 seconds but it perfectly sums up the accounting dynamic. I think we need to hear it. My boyfriend Bob Vance from Vance Refrigeration gave me a Vance Refrigeration credit card only for emergencies. An emergency like you have an ice cream cake and you're in the sun and it's melting? You don't use it to buy refrigerators, Kevin. Don't yell at me. Okay.
Twenty seconds and I thought it summed up the accounting department so well. They did write to your dynamic very well in that moment. Well we got this fan question from Christine D in Los Angeles who said, was it scripted for Phyllis to scoot away in her chair after being questioned? Because it really made me laugh out loud. No. No, it was not. In the script, it just said she leaves.
Yeah, that is something we completely found on the day Phyllis started to scoot away in her chair. We thought it was hilarious and it just it became part of the scene. Well, if you think about how far she has to go I mean it's not like she's scoot she has to scoot on that chair like around another desk to get back to her spot. So far but again by doing this little joke meant that Randall didn't have to see the bullpen. Yep. She doesn't walk away the The camera doesn't follow her. Instead she's scooching in her chair. It's perfect. Next up is episode 3. It's titled Meredith. The accountants are now
questioning Meredith in the kitchen regarding the missing money. In the kitchen and you notice the camera is shooting toward the annex. Yeah. We got a fan question from Tiffany L. in Wisconsin. Tiffany says that three minutes and 34 seconds when Angela says, idiot, now we don't have the element of surprise. That sounded very much like something Dwight would say. Was that a nod to Dwight? Tiffany, I thought the same thing.
I actually thought this whole speech was very Dwight. Here's how it would have gone on in the script. It's impossible to trap her and we won't be able to register the look on her face when we ask her if she stole $3,000. Angela whips her head over to Meredith, hoping to notice something. Meredith says, you think I stole $3,000?
Angela says, oh, we know you did, or someone else did. This does sound like dialogue Dwight could say. Right? It does. He would try to say something shocking and then read your reaction. Mm-hmm. Very Dwight.
Well, now, thanks to the webisodes, we are finally going to learn some information about Meredith. Lauren Kay from Columbus, Ohio noticed and said, we finally know about Meredith's second child. Her name is Wendy. And Meredith's ex-husband took her. Yeah, Meredith says he got the good one.
Oh, Meredith. Meredith is gonna swear she would never steal any company money. She would not jeopardize her kid. She just wants to know if anyone wants to grab a beer basically. Yeah a red stripe. It's like 11 in the morning. I loved Kate's delivery when as Meredith she says so so that's too early. I have never felt so shamed as the time that we had some people over to swim at our
Oh，梅雷迪思。梅雷迪思会发誓她绝不会偷公司的钱。她绝不会拿她孩子的未来冒险。基本上，她只是想知道有没有人想去喝杯啤酒。对，来杯红条啤酒。当时大概早上11点。我太喜欢凯特演梅雷迪思时说“那是太早了”的语气了。我从来没有像那次我们请一些人到家里来游泳，
house and we were gonna do like a noon barbecue and I offered this other mom a glass of wine. It's a barbecue. It's a weekend barbecue. I thought that was okay and she said it's not even noon. And I was like well the food's gonna come out soon and I really, still to this day I feel so embarrassed. I'm like was that, what does she think of me?
然后我们打算搞个中午的烧烤，我问另一个妈妈要不要来杯葡萄酒时感到那么羞耻。那是个烧烤。是个周末烧烤。我觉得这没问题，但她说甚至还没到中午。我就想，好吧，食物一会儿就上来，直到今天我还是觉得很尴尬。我就想，是不是……她是怎么看我的？
She was like someone we didn't know well and. Oh, who cares? Who cares what she thinks? Well, I was Meredith in that moment. You are no, you are no Meredith. I barely drank. I know, let me tell you, that lady couldn't hang with my tennis gals.
她就像那种我们不太熟的人。噢，谁在乎呢？谁在乎她怎么想？好吧，那一刻我就是梅雷迪思。你才不是，你才不是梅雷迪思。我几乎不喝酒。我知道，我跟你说，那位女士可比不上我网球圈的姐妹们。
I didn't think it was so weird. I was like, what's the difference between? Having a glass of wine with your barbecue that coming out we can on my weekend There are circumstances here at play having like a Bloody Mary or a mimosa with breakfast I mean, I've never done that because that feels early to me. I don't understand that. I can't hair of the dog, whatever that is. I can't have that at like 10 a.m. or whatever. Right. I get that. This is the same way I feel about a pastry in the morning. How is, let's say, a little piece of coffee cake any different than a muffin? Well it's not and it's why you'll have a full-on piece
我觉得这没那么奇怪。我就在想，有什么区别呢？在烧烤时喝一杯葡萄酒跟……周末的时候会有各种情况，比如在早餐时喝血玛丽或含羞草鸡尾酒。我的意思是，我从来没那样做过，因为我觉得那样有点太早了。我不能理解那种做法。什么“以毒攻毒”之类的。我没办法在早上10点左右或者类似的时候喝那个。对。我懂这种感觉。这就跟我对早上的糕点那种感觉一样。凭什么，比方说，一块咖啡蛋糕跟一个松饼有什么不同？好吧，根本没不同，这就是为什么你会
of pie with breakfast. Yes I will. Oh I can't wait. I know it's almost time lady. There's gonna be all this extra pie in your house so soon. The only thing I ever asked for for my birthday and for Christmas is a chocolate meringue pie. My husband makes the best chocolate meringue pie. Look I have to curse because it's that good. And then you have a piece for breakfast. I do or I just get out the pie pan and stand in the pantry with a fork and eat it. Sorry I got a little excited there. Where are we? Well bottom line is Meredith didn't do it. Meredith did not do it.
在吃早餐时来一大块派。没错，我就是会。噢，我已经等不及了。我知道，快到时间了，女士。你家很快就会有各种多余的派了。我过生日和过圣诞节唯一会要求的东西就是巧克力蛋白霜派。我丈夫做的巧克力蛋白霜派是最好的。听着，我得爆粗口，因为它太好吃了。然后你早餐就可以吃一块。我确实会，或者我直接把派盘拿出来，手里拿个叉子站在食品储藏室里吃。抱歉，刚才我有点兴奋过头了。我们说到哪了？好吧，最底线就是梅雷迪思没做这事。梅雷迪思绝对没做这事。
We're on to episode number four called Stanley. Yes we're back in the conference room. The accountants are questioning Stanley regarding the missing money. He is delighted by this. Kevin is going to have our recap talking head where he explains what's going on and then Oscar tells Stanley, listen I know it's not you but I have to ask anyway and Stanley says he hopes whoever did it gets away with it. I know. Stanley says in fact if he finds out who it is he's gonna shake their hand, pat them on the back, and give them 72 hours to flee the country before telling us who it is.
我们继续看第四集，名叫《斯坦利》。对，我们回到了会议室。会计们正在就失踪的钱盘问斯坦利。他对此感到非常高兴。凯文有一段回顾剧情的单人采访，他在里面解释发生了什么，然后奥斯卡对斯坦利说，听着，我知道不是你，但我无论如何都得问一下。斯坦利则说，他希望干这事的人能逃过法网。我知道。斯坦利甚至说，如果他查出是谁干的，他要跟对方握手，拍拍对方的背，并给对方72小时逃离这个国家，然后才告诉我们是谁干的。
That made me laugh. I'm like, what? I love that he has a whole exit strategy for this person. I really noticed the tight angles on this particular scene. Randall was working very hard to avoid shooting through the window to the bullpen. When Leslie, as Stanley, gets up to leave, you do see Kate sitting at her desk in the background. And it's fast because the whole rest of the bullpen is just empty. As Stanley leaves the room, Kevin says, I don't think it was him.
这把我逗笑了。我就想，什么？我太喜欢他给这个人安排了一整套逃跑计划了。我特别注意到这个特定场景中紧凑的角度。兰德尔非常努力地避免把镜头对着通往办公大区的窗户。当莱斯利扮演的斯坦利起身离开时，你确实能看到凯特坐在背景的办公桌旁。而且这个镜头很短暂，因为整个办公大区其余的地方都是空的。当斯坦利离开房间时，凯文说，我觉得不是他。
And Angela says, really, genius? This leads to a Kevin talking head that I loved and I think we need to hear it. Angela thinks it's an insult when she calls me a genius, all sarcastic and whatnot. But technically, guess what? I am a genius. When I was a kid, I took an IQ test and I scored over a hundred so joke is on you Angela. We're finding out all these things about the background characters on the show and that's one of the things I love about the webisodes. Yes and you know what when we were texting with Brian he shared with us a story about shooting this talking head. It's really fun. I want you to hear it.
安吉拉说，真的吗，天才？这引发了一段凯文的单人采访，我超喜欢，我觉得我们得听听。安吉拉觉得当我讽刺挖苦地称我为天才时这是在侮辱我。但严格来说，你猜怎么着？我就是个天才。我小时候做过智商测试，得分超过了一百，所以被打脸了吧，安吉拉。我们正在发掘剧中这些背景角色的所有故事，这就是我喜欢这些网络短剧的原因之一。对，你知道吗，当我们跟布莱恩发信息时，他跟我们分享了一个关于拍摄这段单人采访的故事。真的很有趣。我想让你们听听。
So here's my favorite story from the accountants webisode series. By the way, Angela, Jenna, audience listening, I just arrived, no joke, back in to Scranton, Pennsylvania. I am at the rad, the Radisson Hotel. I've arrived here. I'm very, very excited to be back and now to be talking to you guys about the accountants. Here's my story. We're filming.
所以这是我来自《会计师》网络短剧系列中最喜欢的故事。顺便说一句，安吉拉、詹娜以及在听的观众们，我刚刚回到宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿，真的不夸张。我正在那家很酷的雷迪森酒店。我到这儿了。我非常非常高兴能回来，现在能和你们一起聊聊《会计师》。这是我的故事。我们在拍戏。
No one else is on set. Me, you, Angela and Oscar. We are recording and I'm recording a talking head, a direct address to the camera and we're in the annex back my back was to like the room with the snacks and by Toby's desk and I'm recording a talking head and I'm talking to camera and just behind the camera I see as we're recording Greg Daniels walk by and I see my old friend from high school Ed Helms walk by the camera. Now in that moment I'm not thinking oh there's Ed Helms star of The Daily Show comedian and actor. My brain didn't go there. My brain went back to high school in Atlanta, Georgia. I was like, Ed Helms? Why is my old buddy Ed Helms on the office set? Come to find out he was there meeting
片场没有别人。就我、你、安吉拉和奥斯卡。我们在录制，我在录一段单人采访，也就是直接对着镜头说话，我们在套间里，我的背对着放零食的那个房间，就在托比的办公桌旁边，我在录单人采访，我在对着镜头说话，就在镜头后面，我看到我们录制时格雷格·丹尼尔斯走过，我看到我在高中时的老朋友埃德·海尔姆斯从镜头前走过。在那一刻，我脑子里想的根本不是“哦，那是《每日秀》的明星、喜剧演员兼演员埃德·海尔姆斯”。我的大脑没有往那儿想。我的大脑回到了佐治亚州亚特兰大的高中时代。我当时就想，埃德·海尔姆斯？为什么我的老伙计埃德·海尔姆斯会出现在《办公室》的片场？后来才知道他是来跟
with Greg. He had a deal with NBC and he was meeting with Greg about joining the office in season three. This was his introductory meeting with Greg Daniels. So I saw him, gave him a hug, and remember saying so specifically, why are you here? Which in retrospect, it was very embarrassing. That is so crazy. Isn't that so wild?
格雷格开会的。他和NBC有合作，他是来跟格雷格讨论在第三季加入《办公室》的事。这是他与格雷格·丹尼尔斯的初次会面。所以我看到他了，给了他一个拥抱，并且记得自己非常具体地问了这样一句话：你为什么会在这里？现在回想起来，这真是太尴尬了。这太疯狂了。是不是超离谱？
And I totally hear that. You know when you see someone completely out of contact and you can't connect the dots? I just thought that was so wild to see your old high school friend all of a sudden at your place of work. You're like, what's happening? Well we also got several fan questions about Kevin's talking head, where he's talking about his IQ score. One is from Amelia S. in Akron, Ohio, who said,
我完全理解那种感觉。你知道当你完全在不合时宜的场合看到某个人，然后脑回路连不上时的感觉吗？我只是觉得在你的工作场所突然看到你的高中老朋友这事太离谱了。你会想，这到底是怎么回事？好吧，我们还收到了几个关于凯文单人采访的粉丝提问，他在采访中谈到了自己的智商分数。其中一个来自俄亥俄州阿克伦的艾梅莉亚·S，她说：
please do a breakdown deep dive on IQs or IQ tests. And Ivy from Canada said, Kevin says he scored over 100 on an IQ test. The average IQ in the world in the 1970s, estimating when he may have taken it, was 90. Average IQ has dropped over the years. It was 87 in 2024. But nonetheless, does this mean that Kevin
请对智商或智商测试做一个深入的深度剖析。来自加拿大的艾维说，凯文说他在智商测试中得分超过100。20世纪70年代（估算他可能测试的时间）世界上的平均智商是90。多年来平均智商一直在下降。2024年是87。但尽管如此，这是否意味着凯文
had an above average IQ as a child? Well, you know I've never been so excited to deep dive something. I was gonna say, I mean, this call to action from Amelia, you must have been like, hey. I was very excited. I was also very intrigued when Ivy said that IQ scores had been dropping.
小时候拥有高于平均水平的智商？好吧，你知道我从来没有对深入剖析某个东西这么兴奋过。我正想说，艾梅莉亚发出的这个号召，你当时一定觉得，太棒了。我当时超级兴奋。当艾维说智商分数一直在下降时，我也非常感兴趣。
I had to know everything. All right, here's what I found out. There are so many different IQ tests, and they all have different ways that they score. But in general, almost all of them say that 100 is like their median score. And so in general, a score of 85 to 114 signifies average intelligence. So what we've learned is that Kevin is of average intelligence according to his reporting of his IQ score. Although Kevin thinks he's a genius. I guess so. If you have an IQ score of 115 to 129,
我得把一切都弄个明白。好吧，这就是我发现的情况。有那么多不同的智商测试，它们的评分方式各不相同。但总的来说，几乎所有的测试都说100是它们的中间分。所以总体而言，85到114的分数代表平均智商。所以我们了解到的是，根据凯文自己汇报的智商分数，他属于平均智商。尽管凯文觉得自己是个天才。我想是的。如果你的智商分数在115到129之间，
you are above average or bright. If your score is 130 to 144, you are moderately gifted. 30 to 144, you are moderately gifted. 145 to 159 is highly gifted. And it is estimated that Einstein's IQ was around 160. Dang. I love that. That's my response to someone who's really smart. Like dang, dang. That's impressive stuff. You go Einstein. I'm so proud of you. Well, about 98% of people have a score 130 or below.
你高于平均水平或者很聪明。如果你的分数是130到144，你属于中度天赋。30到144，你属于中度天赋。145到159是高度天赋。据估计爱因斯坦的智商大约是160。天哪。我太喜欢这个了。这就是我对那些真正聪明的人的回应。比如天哪，天哪。这真是令人印象深刻的东西。真有你的，爱因斯坦。我为你感到骄傲。好吧，大约98%的人分数在130或以下。
Only 2% of the population score above that. So only 2% of people are considered moderately to highly gifted. Okay. According to 2019's the intelligence of the nation's report the average IQ in the United States was 97.43. Oh where is this leading? Where do we rank? We're doing well globally. Okay. There was a 2010 study. It took the scores of 108 nations and found that the average IQ across that global sample was 89. Now it's very important to
只有2%的人口得分高于这个分数。所以只有2%的人被认为具有中度到高度天赋。好吧，根据2019年《国家智商报告》，美国的平均智商是97.43。噢，这导向何方？我们的排名如何？我们在全球表现不错。好吧，曾有过一项2010年的研究。它采集了108个国家的得分，发现该全球样本的平均智商是89。现在非常重要的一点是，
note that these kinds of tests can be misinterpreted. They can be culturally biased. Different countries have different ideas of what intelligence is and how to measure it. In fact, IQ testing is sometimes considered controversial because intelligence measurements, they can be misinterpreted. They can be misused to stigmatize marginalized groups. Also, most IQ tests do not evaluate other important aspects of human functioning like emotional intelligence.
要注意这类测试可能会被误解。它们可能存在文化偏见。不同的国家对什么是智商以及如何衡量智商有不同的看法。事实上，智商测试有时被认为是有争议的，因为智商测量结果可能会被误解。它们可能会被滥用来给边缘化群体贴上污名化标签。此外，大多数智商测试并不评估人类运作的其他重要方面，比如情商。
No offense to Kevin. I'm not sure he's gonna score very highly in that category either. I'm thinking not. Okay. All of that said, it is true that IQ test scores have been dropping since the turn of the millennium and many experts believe that it is because we have upped our reliance on technology that we simply do not use our brains as
无意冒犯凯文。我不确定他在那个类别里能得高分。我觉得不会。好吧。说了这么多，智商测试分数自千禧之年以来一直在下降这一事实确实存在，许多专家认为，这是因为我们对技术的依赖增加了，导致我们根本不怎么用脑了。
much. Well that tracks I think. Yeah. Like we all want to find the shortcut, right? I feel like I've gotten dumber since my smartphone. I do. Remember I used to add things without a calculator? I can't even do that anymore. Have you ever taken an IQ test? No. Cassie, Sam, have y'all?
好吧，这说得通，我觉得。对。就像我们都想找捷径，对吧？我觉得自从有了智能手机，我变笨了。真的。还记得我以前不用计算器就能加减数字吗？我现在甚至都做不到了。你做过智商测试吗？没有。卡西、萨姆，你们做过吗？
No, I haven't. Yeah, not officially. Not officially? I mean, there's like online ones, but. Oh yeah. I was tested as a child. Oh, you were so smart They pulled you aside. I did quite well. You did a real flex there with your face You did a little bit like
没有，我没有。对，没有正式测过。没有正式测过？我是说，有那种网上的测试，但是……噢，对。我小时候测过。噢，你太聪明了，他们把你单独叫到一边。我考得相当好。你在那儿还真显摆了一下你的表情你当时有点像
Bag it up bag it up. I mean this bitch is so smarty I mean, I know that they're unreliable and blah blah blah But I did well. I skipped a grade as a result of my IQ test. What grade did you skip? How am I never, I've never heard this information about you. So did you ask us ours just so you could say yours? Yes, yes she did.
收起来，收起来。我是说这丫头太聪明了吧。我的意思是，我知道它们不可靠，巴拉巴拉，但我考得不错。因为我的智商测试，我跳过了一级。你跳了几级？为什么我从来……我从来没听过关于你的这个信息？所以你问我们的分数只是为了能说出你自己的？对，对，她就是这意思。
No, I skipped kindergarten. Okay. They moved me ahead to first grade. When I was in high school and I was looking at colleges, I knew that I wanted to be an actor but I wasn't ready to sort of I guess admit it maybe. Like I was trying to be practical so I enrolled as a pre-law history major in college and I thought that if I was gonna become a lawyer it might help me on my resume if I was a member of Mensa. So Mensa is a club for people with very high IQs.
不，我跳过的是幼儿园。好吧。他们把我直接提到了一年级。当我上高中并开始考虑大学时，我知道我想成为一名演员，但我还没准备好去承认它，也许吧。就像我当时在试着表现得很现实，所以我在大学里注册成了法学预科历史专业，我想如果我要成为一名律师，如果我是门萨俱乐部的成员，可能会对我的简历有所帮助。所以门萨是给智商极高的人准备的俱乐部。
We know what Mensa is. Yeah, we do. Well, I wanted to explain it to all y'all. Listen, I'm sorry, we didn't skip kindergarten. We didn't skip crayons and coloring and playing with Play-Doh. We know what Mensa is. But we know Mensa.
我们知道什么是门萨。对，我们知道。好吧，我只是想跟你们所有人都解释一下。听着，对不起，我们可没有跳过幼儿园。我们没有跳过蜡笔、填色和玩橡皮泥。我们知道什么是门萨。但是我们知道门萨。
All right. Well, anyway, I didn't qualify. Is the end of that story. Two of my cousins are in Mensa. They're in Mensa? They were tested as children and both are in Mensa and they're sisters. Yeah. Wow. That's a smart family. Wicked smart family. Which is fun,
好吧。总之，我没有达到资格。这个故事的结局就是这样。我的两个表妹都是门萨会员。她们是门萨会员？她们小时候接受了测试，都是门萨会员，而且她们是亲姐妹。对。哇。真是个聪明的家族。绝顶聪明的家族。这就很有趣了，
because they just love Pokemon and Five Nights at Freddy's. And I'm like, how are you in MENSA? Well, my dad qualified. He never joined, but my score, I didn't make the cut. Aw. But, you know, it's all right. I think you're doing okay. I'm doing all right. I think you're doing okay. I'm doing all right.
因为她们只喜欢宝可梦和《玩具熊的五夜后宫》。我就在想，你们俩是怎么进门萨的？好吧，我爸爸符合资格。他从没加入过，但我测的分数，我没达到标准。啊。不过，你知道的，没关系。我觉得你现在过得挺好。我过得挺好。我觉得你现在过得挺好。我过得挺好。
I think you're doing just fine. I'm gonna be fine. There you have it. I also found the ranking of average IQ scores that go state by state through the US. But I don't wanna make anyone angry. But I'd like to say congratulations, Massachusetts, you're number one.
我觉得你过得挺不错的。我会好起来的。事情就是这样。我还找到了全美各州的平均智商排名。但我不想惹任何人生气。不过我想说恭喜马萨诸塞州，你们是第一名。
Oh. Yeah. It is home to say congratulations Massachusetts, you're number one. Oh. Yeah. It is home to MIT and Harvard, so. A lot of universities are in Massachusetts, so many. Their average state score was 104.3. That's very good. Yes, well done. California's was very low.
噢。对。这里是……恭喜马萨诸塞州，你们是第一名。噢。对。这里是麻省理工和哈佛的所在地，所以。马萨诸塞州有好多大学，太多了。他们全州的平均分是104.3。这非常高。对，干得漂亮。加利福尼亚州的很低。
Oh. Third from the bottom. Oh, well, man, okay. 95.5 here in California. Got some work to do there. Yeah. Kevin would be crushing it in California. I should have looked up Pennsylvania, since that's where all of our Scranton folks are
噢。倒数第三。噢，好吧，伙计，好吧。加利福尼亚州这里是95.5。还有一些工作要做啊。对。凯文在加利福尼亚州肯定能混得风生水起。我本来应该查一下宾夕法尼亚州的，因为那是我们所有斯克兰顿老乡
from. That's where Kevin is from. Yes. Didn't do it. Didn't do it. If I'd been in Mensa, I might have thought of it. Maybe. Well, there you have it. There you
的老家。那是凯文的老家。对。没干这事。没干这事。如果我是门萨会员，我可能就能想到了。也许吧。好吧，事情就是这样。事情就是
have it. You did skip kindergarten and no one can ever take that away from you. That's right. I really wanted to go to kindergarten too. Oh this just took a turn. I remember starting at school and walking past the kindergarten room and it looked so fun. It is fun. Well I wouldn't know. Oh I had to go straight to a desk and learn math. Oh we should do another craft night. Would that make you feel good? We did a little crafting again. Remember how we painted those cats on a fence? It might be why I like that stuff so much. Because you didn't get to do it. I didn't. Well, this webisode ends with the accountants brainstorming who to interrogate next.
这样。你确实跳过了幼儿园，谁也夺不走这段经历。没错。我也真的很想去幼儿园。噢，这话题急转直下了。我记得刚上学时走过幼儿园的教室，看起来太有趣了。确实有趣。好吧，我可无从得知。噢，我不得不直接去坐课桌前学数学。噢，我们应该再搞个手工之夜。那样会让你感觉好点吗？我们以前做过一点手工艺。还记得我们在栅篷上画猫吗？这可能就是为什么我那么喜欢那些东西的原因。因为你没机会做。我没有。好吧，这集的网络短剧以会计们集思广益接下来要审讯谁而结束。
They're kind of stumped. They're sort of looking at their notepads, like thumping their pens. By the way, Oscar's notepad has no words on it. None. It's like half of a tic-tac-toe board or something. I don't know what is on there. I know.
他们有点被难住了。他们一边看着记事本，一边敲着笔。顺便说一句，奥斯卡的记事本上一个字也没有。一个字都没有。就像半个井字棋盘什么的。我不知道上面有什么。我知道。
And then Oscar shares, you know, my mom visits at the worst time. half of a tic-tac-toe board or something. I don't know what is on there. I know. And then Oscar shares, you know, my mom visits at the worst time. All of a sudden it's just a personal life share. I loved it. This is what life is like at work. You're like working, you're working, then you're like, oh, by the way, da-da-da-da-da.
然后奥斯卡分享说，你知道的，我妈妈总是在最糟糕的时候来访。半个井字棋盘什么的。我不知道上面有什么。我知道。然后奥斯卡分享说，你知道的，我妈妈总是在最糟糕的时候来访。突然这就成了私人生活的分享。我太喜欢了。这就是工作中的生活。你一边工作，一边工作，然后你突然就说，哦，对了，哒哒哒哒哒。
So he explains that his mom is visiting at the same time his friends are visiting and they normally get together to ironically watch Prince of Tides. It's like their Rocky Horror Picture Show. They make fun of it. But now he can't go because his mom is here. And Kevin's like, I haven't seen it. And then Angela says, you know what, can we just focus?
所以他解释说，他妈妈来访的时间和他的朋友们来访的时间撞上了，他们通常会聚在一起带着讽刺意味地观看《潮浪王子》。这就像是他们的《洛基恐怖秀》。他们会取笑这部电影。但现在他去不了了，因为他妈妈在这儿。然后凯文就说，我没看过。接着安吉拉说，你知道吗，我们能专心点吗？
And there's this pause and I love it so much. I thought the timing was so great. Then Kevin says, I've never seen it. And Oscar goes, oh it's so bad. And you can tell they're about to drive her crazy. And in the script you had a line, Ange, that got cut. I know. You, under your breath, you were supposed to say, I loved it. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. All right, well listen, why don't we take a break and then when we come back, Roy isn't accounting Angela can't believe it. Well, you know, there are some theories about this.
然后这里有一个停顿，我超级喜欢。我觉得这个时机太棒了。接着凯文说，我从来没看过。奥斯卡就说，哦，那片烂透了。你能看出他们快要把她逼疯了。在剧本里，安吉拉，你本来有句台词被删掉了。我知道。你本来应该小声嘀咕着说，我超喜欢。对。对。没错。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来时，罗伊竟然成了会计，安吉拉简直不敢相信。好吧，你知道的，关于这个有一些理论。
We are back with episode number five. It's titled, Someone in the Warehouse. Yeah. This webisode is going to start with Oscar, Angela, and Kevin. They're all over by Kevin's desk in the accounting nook. We had never filmed a scene like this, where Oscar and I just wedged deep in that corner. If you go to 14 seconds, you can see how the scene is framed. And you know, Randall was brainstorming again,
我们带着第五集回来了。标题是《仓库里有人》。对。这部网络短剧从奥斯卡、安吉拉和凯文开始。他们都在会计角落凯文的办公桌周围。我们以前从未拍过这样的场景，我和奥斯卡被死死挤在那个角落里。如果你拉到14秒，你能看到这个场景是如何构图的。你知道的，兰德尔又在集思广益了，
how can we be in a scene where we don't see the bullpen? And I have to say, this is a new accounting stack. Normally we're at the copier. Stacked in a corner this time. Stacked in a corner. Yeah, you know, Oscar says, I don't think it's someone in the office. And Angela says it has to be.
我们怎么才能拍一场看不到办公大区的戏呢？我得说，这是一个新的会计区布局。通常我们在复印机旁。这次挤在一个角落里。挤在一个角落里。对，你知道的，奥斯卡说，我觉得不是办公室里的人。安吉拉说一定是的。
I have a improv moment here. Okay. So when we went to do our talking heads, you know Randall would ask us questions. That's what we would always do to kind of get us into the moment, get our character talking. And the talking head they picked for me
这里我有个即兴发挥的时刻。好吧。当我们去做单人采访时，你知道兰德尔会问我们问题。我们总是这么做，好让我们进入状态，让我们的角色开始说话。他们为我挑的那段单人采访
was one that I improvised an answer to Randall. It wasn't the scripted one they wrote for me. And I thought you could hear a little bit of my southern accent in it. Let's hear it. Yeah, I do think it's someone in this office, which really breaks my heart to tell you the truth because I thought we were all good people here. Yeah, I heard it when you said breaks my heart. Breaks my heart because I thought we're all good people here.
是我对兰德尔的问题即兴发挥回答的一段。那不是他们为我写好的剧本台词。我觉得你能在里面听到我的一点南方口音。我们听听看。对，我确实觉得是这个办公室里的人说实话，这真的让我很心碎，因为我以为我们这里所有人都是好人。对，当你说“让我很心碎”时我听出来了。让我很心碎，因为我以为我们这里所有人都是好人。
So that wasn't scripted, but I love that we got to play around like that in these talking head moments. Well, their next strategy is to focus on the warehouse. Could it be Roy? I mean, he's getting married soon, but Angela does not think Roy would do it. He just has too much character. That's right. And Kevin goes, hold up. wait a second, you like Roy. And she's like, no we don't.
所以那不是剧本写好的，但我很喜欢我们在这些单人采访的时刻这样即兴发挥。好吧，他们的下一个策略是将重点放在仓库上。会是罗伊吗？我是说，他很快就要结婚了，但安吉拉觉得罗伊不会干这种事。他这人太有品格了。没错。然后凯文说，等等。等一下，你喜欢罗伊。她就说，不，我们才没有。
That's improbable, I mean inappropriate. We got a fan question from Lydia in Sweden who said, Angela having a crush on Roy, is this supposed to have happened before or after Roy chose Angela in the episode The Fire. This was after. This would have been after. Yes.
这太不可能了，我是说这太不合规矩了。我们收到了来自瑞典莉迪亚的一个粉丝提问，她说，安吉拉暗恋罗伊，这应该是发生在罗伊在《火灾》那一集选择安吉拉之前还是之后？这是之后。这应该是在那之后。对。
Yeah, you know, we've been asked this before during the rewatch, and I do think Angela was a little smitten with Roy. Yeah. And Kevin being like Angela's idiot brother is so tickled by this. He is really going to tease her. Yes.
对，你知道的，在重看期间以前有人问过我们这个问题，我确实觉得安吉拉对罗伊有点迷恋。对。而凯文就像安吉拉那个白痴弟弟一样，对此感到开心极了。他真的要取笑她了。对。
He has a talking head where he's just doing that song. Roy and Angela sitting in a tree. But then Angela walks behind him and yells at him to cut it out. Cut it out, Kevin. I noticed that Stanley was in the background. And we also got a fan question from Tharia D in Spain who said, when Angela is passing by the other side of the windows and yells at Kevin to shut up, does this mean that all along people have been able to hear talking heads in the office?
他有一段单人采访，他就在那儿唱那首歌。罗伊和安吉拉坐在树上。但接着安吉拉从他身后走过，冲他大喊让他闭嘴。闭嘴，凯文。我注意到斯坦利在背景里。我们还收到了西班牙塔里亚·D的一个粉丝提问，她说，当安吉拉从窗户的另一边走过并冲凯文大喊让他闭嘴时，这是否意味着大家一直以来都能听到办公室里的单人采访？
It got me thinking about how many gossips people could have heard. That's a really good question. I mean, you have to think in this instance, Kevin Kevin is singing so maybe it's like a little louder. But my character has a few times where she is in the background of a talking head and she's ticked off. Yep they did do that with you a lot didn't they? Yeah. Well now Roy is in accounting and he's being questioned. And I noticed something really creative that Randall did here with his camera work. The scene opens with one of the few wider shots. He placed Kate in the foreground at her desk,
这让我开始思考大家到底能听到多少八卦。这是个非常好的问题。我是说，你得考虑到在这种情况下，凯文在唱歌，所以声音可能稍微大了一点。但我的角色有好几次出现在单人采访的背景里而且她被惹毛了。对，他们经常让你这么干，对吧？对。好了，现在罗伊成了会计，正在接受盘问。我注意到了兰德尔在这里的镜头运用中做了一些非常具有创意的处理。场景开场是一个罕见的较宽的镜头。他把凯特安排在前景的办公桌旁，
but he very quickly then punches in. But he gives you a sense for one moment of that wider office view. Mm-hmm. And Roy's gonna say, you know what? I wouldn't do that, I don't steal. And even if I wanted to, I wouldn't know how to. And Kevin lays it all out for him.
但随后他非常迅速地推成了特写。不过他让你有那么一瞬间感受到了那个更开阔的办公室视野。嗯哼。罗伊会说，你知道吗？我不会干那种事，我不偷东西。就算我想偷，我也不知道怎么偷。凯文把一切都给他摆在明面上了。
Kevin's like, well, you'd have to take it from petty cash. Roy's like, I don't even know where you keep it. Kevin says, in Oscar's drawer. Roy says, well, isn't it locked? Kevin goes, well, he keeps the key behind the counter. And Oscar's like, Kevin, why are you telling him how to steal and Roy's like no I wouldn't do that it's wrong and Angela's like well I'm satisfied thank you for your time
凯文就说，好吧，你得从备用金里拿。罗伊说，我甚至不知道你们把钱放哪儿。凯文说，在奥斯卡的抽屉里。罗伊说，那不是锁着的吗？凯文说，嗯，他把钥匙放在柜台后面。奥斯卡就说，凯文，你干嘛告诉他怎么偷钱啊？罗伊说，不，我不会干那种事，这是不对的。安吉拉就说，好吧，我很满意，谢谢你抽出时间。
mm-hmm and then Kevin says Roy one more question what do you think of Angela and I have an improv moment what was it when Oscar says you don't have to answer that and Kevin says but you can if you want to. That was improv. I like that a lot. All right. Episode number six is titled The Memo. At this point, the accountants have ruled out Phyllis, Stanley, Jim, Meredith and themselves. Although Angela isn't so sure about that. Kevin has a talking head where he says he didn't steal it and Angela says she is positive. It's not Dwight. He has the most integrity of anyone in the office Yes, and then they stare at her oddly. So just a reminder
嗯哼，然后凯文说，罗伊，最后一个问题，你觉得安吉拉怎么样？我有一个即兴发挥的时刻。是什么时候？当奥斯卡说你不用回答那个问题时，凯文说，但如果你想回答的话可以回答。那是即兴发挥。我很喜欢那个。好吧。第六集标题是《备忘录》。此时，会计们已经排除了菲利斯、斯坦利、吉姆、梅雷迪思以及他们自己。尽管安吉拉对最后一点并不是很确定。凯文有一段单人采访，他说他没偷，安吉拉说她百分之百确定。不是德怀特。他在办公室里是最有品格的人。没错，然后他们奇怪地盯着她。所以提醒一下，
This was released between season 2 and season 3 So the audience knows that Dwight and Angela are a couple, but the people in the office will not find out until season five. Yeah. When Phyllis spills the beans in Moroccan Christmas. Yeah. So I loved that we sprinkled this in to the webisode. Well up next is one of my favorite lines of the Accountants Webisode series.
这一集是在第二季和第三季之间发布的，所以观众们知道德怀特和安吉拉是一对，但办公室里的人直到第五季才会发现。对。当菲利斯在《摩洛哥圣诞节》里说漏嘴的时候。对。所以我很喜欢我们把这个小细节穿插进网络短剧中。好吧，接下来是《会计师》网络短剧系列中我最喜欢的台词之一。
What is it? Angela says to Oscar, did you talk to Kelly? Oscar says yes. She told me she didn't do it. And then 45 minutes later the conversation ended. Yes, that's right. to Oscar, did you talk to Kelly? Oscar says yes, she told me she didn't do it and then 45 minutes later the conversation ended. Yes, that's right. And then Kevin says he talked to Creed and he didn't do it either, although he did offer
是什么？安吉拉对奥斯卡说，你跟凯莉谈过吗？奥斯卡说谈过了。她告诉我她没干这事。然后45分钟后对话才结束。对，没错。对奥斯卡说，你跟凯莉谈过吗？奥斯卡说谈过了，她告诉我她没干这事，然后45分钟后对话才结束。对，没错。接着凯文说他跟克里德谈过了，他也没干这事，虽然他确实提出
to sell me some dietary supplements. Well they decide that they're going to write a memo. But first they're going to argue over who gets to write it. That's right. Angela says I'll write it and then Kevin says no, I want to write it. That's right. Angela says, I'll write it. And then Kevin says, no, I want to write it. And Kevin's like, come on, you never let me write accounting memos. And Angela says, fine, but I'll supervise. I want to point out that Kate, Leslie, and Phyllis are all
要向我兜售一些膳食补充剂。好吧，他们决定写一份备忘录。但首先他们要为谁来写这份备忘录争论一番。没错。安吉拉说我来写，然后凯文说不，我想写。没错。安吉拉说，我来写。然后凯文说，不，我想写。凯文就说，拜托，你从来不让我写会计备忘录。安吉拉说，好吧，但我来监督。我要指出的是，凯特、莱斯利和菲利斯都在
in the background of this. This is the most filled out this rest of this bullpen world has been in any of the webisodes. So I don't know what happened with everyone's schedule, but everyone was there at the same time for this scene. For this one moment. And Randall took advantage of it. Well, I have an improv moment. As we're leaving the conference room, I improvise shutting
这个场景的背景里。这是所有网络短剧中办公大区的其他人出场最齐的一次。所以我不知道大家的日程是怎么安排的，但为了这一场戏，每个人都在同一时间到场了。就为了这短暂的一刻。兰德尔好好利用了这一点。好吧，我有一个即兴发挥的时刻。当我们离开会议室时，我即兴做了一个把身后的门关上的动作，我知道凯文就紧跟在我身后，他差点一头撞上去。我重看这一段时觉得搞笑极了，如果你切到那一刻，你能听到布莱恩以凯文的口吻说“天哪”，因为他太恼火了。这每次都把我逗笑，因为布莱恩和我以前经常这样捉弄对方。你们确实会。当我们一起拍戏时，
the door behind me, knowing that Kevin is right behind me and he'd almost walk into it. I got so tickled rewatching this because if you go to that moment, you can hear Brian as Kevin say, God, because he is so annoyed. And it makes me laugh every time because Brian and I would do stuff like this to each other. You would. When we were in scenes together,
我们喜欢这样互相恶搞，他真的就像我从未有过的兄弟。这就是我在捉弄他。好吧，现在凯文在打备忘录，但安吉拉在旁边对他的肩膀指手画脚。他显然不知道把日期右对齐是什么意思。没有。我是说，这就是我们刚才讨论的。现在我们的电脑会帮我们写备忘录。我们不需要学习正确的备忘录或信件书写格式了。
we'd like to like mess around with each other and he's really like the brother I never had. And this was me just messing with him. Well now Kevin is typing the memo but Angela is micromanaging him over his shoulder. He clearly does not know what it means to make the date right justified. Nope. I mean this is what we were just talking about before. Now like our computers write our memos for us. We don't have to learn proper memo or letter writing.
噢，对，确实。有模板。比如，如果你想写一份简历，有个模板。你填进去就行了。我觉得结果就是我们变笨了。真的。这就是我的抱怨。这就是我对人工智能的抨击。
Oh yeah, for sure. There's templates. Like, if you want to write a resume, there's a template. You just fill it in. I think we're getting dumber as a result. I really do. This is my complaint. This is my soapbox about AI.
我觉得这不好。它帮我们写文章这事我觉得不好。而且我不知道。你知道我对买个新电视遥控器有什么感觉。它能做更多事情并不意味着它就更好。我们并没有比以前空闲。它没有为我们节省任何时间。我们并没有把更多时间花在休闲活动上。
I don't think it's good. I don't think it's good that it's writing our essays for us. And I don't know. You know how I don't think it's good that it's writing our essays for us. And I don't know. You know how I feel about getting a new TV remote. Just because it does more stuff doesn't mean it's better. We're not less busy than we were before. It's not saving us any time. We're not spending more time on leisure activities.
我觉得我们应该这样做。好吧，那是因为我们在国内有那种，你知道的，效率文化。我们崇拜效率。我也饱受这种病的折磨。除非我在产生效益，否则我往往感觉不到自我价值。这是个问题。但它正在损害我们的健康。确实如此。你知道的，肯德拉在她的书《计划》中写过这一点，那一小节真的触动了我。对，总是顶着死线，总是不断地推着自己前进、前进、前进。
And I think we should. Well, it's because we have, you know, productivity culture in this country. We value productivity. I suffer from this same illness. I don't often feel self-esteem unless I'm being productive. It's a problem. But it's affecting our health. It is. You know, Kendra writes about it in her book, The Plan, and it really spoke to me, that section. Yeah, always having a deadline, always pushing, pushing, pushing.
没错，所有这一切据说都是为了所谓的“省时间”，但我们每个人都比以前更忙了。好了，抨击结束，随便吧。反正我确信大家都同意。我这里没说什么新观点。我喜欢你……这不是什么开创性的言论。我最喜欢你结束长篇大论时那种，
Yes, and all of it is supposedly, quote unquote, saving us time, but we're all busier than we were. All right, soapbox over, whatever. I'm sure everyone agrees anyway. I'm not saying any new thoughts here. I like that you- It's nothing groundbreaking. I love it when you end a soapbox with just like,
你就是那种，呃，随便吧，抨击结束的态度。我是说，我很激动，但接着我也觉得，好吧，我不知道。我也累了。你也就是累了。好吧，凯文打算自己写完那份备忘录。他写的是“安吉拉烂透了”。他说他不打算发出去，这只是写给他自己的。
you're just so, ugh, whatever, soapbox over. I mean, I get fired up, but then I'm also like, well, I don't know. I'm also tired. You're also just tired. Well, Kevin is gonna finish his own memo. He wrote Angela stinks. He says he's not gonna hand it out, it's just for him.
事实上，忘掉吧，其实我刚刚说的那些话收回。天哪，我到底都干了些什么？天哪，太搞笑了。他彻底失控了。他觉得自己滑稽极了。他的心理变化过程。然后他说，等等，等一下。别给她看那个。好吧，第七集，情况变得紧张了。这是
In fact, forget, actually I said anything about it. Oh God, what have I done? Oh my gosh, it's so funny. He totally spirals. He's so tickled with himself. His progression. And then he's like, wait, hold on. Don't show her that. All right episode number seven things are getting tense. This is
我个人最喜欢的一集。随着对失踪钱款的搜寻继续，会计们开始反目成仇。我们再次从会计区开始，每个人都坐在自己的办公桌前，他们正在忙着什么。我有一个拽姐鞋履抓拍要分享给你们。是什么？在13秒时，你能看到我坐在桌前时穿的拽姐鞋。这是《办公室》早期的日子，那些是我第一季的经典拽姐鞋。我还想指出一个南方口音的抓拍。是什么？安吉拉在单人采访中说“我们丢了3000美元”时。是什么？安吉拉在单人采访中说“我们丢了3000美元”时情况变得紧张了。情况变得紧张了。你那段回顾剧情的单人采访？嗯哼。你得拍好多那种，比如为我们回顾剧情的不同版本的采访。我拍了，但情况不是紧张，
my personal favorite. Well as the search for the missing money continues the accountants start to turn on one another. We start this over in accounting again everyone is seated at their desk they're working on something. I have a sass catch for you. What is it? At 13 seconds you can see my sass shoes as I sit at my desk. These were the early days of the office and those are my classic season one sass shoes. And I'd also like to point out a southern accent catch. What is it? Angela's talking head when she says we are missing $3,000. What is it? Angela's talking head when she says we are missing $3,000 things are getting tense. Things are getting tense. Your recap talking head? Mm-hmm. You had to do a lot of those, like different versions of recapping the plot for us. I did, but things weren't tense,
而是紧张。我太喜欢这一集了。这是我最喜欢的一集，第七集。我觉得这种会计之间的化学反应太棒了。我喜欢我们发现凯文曾经用备用金赌博。对，2800美元。对。我喜欢安吉拉戴了一条新项链，每个人都注意到了，很显然那是德怀特送的。但她就是不说。
they were tense. They were tense. I just loved this one. This is my favorite, number seven. I just thought it was such great accounting chemistry. I love that we find out that Kevin once gambled with petty cash. Yeah, $2,800. Yes. I love that Angela's wearing a new necklace and everyone notices, and clearly it's from Dwight. But she won't say.
她就是不说。她就是不说，尽管她一直在非常不自然地摆弄着它。我想告诉你们，剧本里写着安吉拉朋友的名字叫黛安·切斯特伯格。在其中一个镜头里我把姓改了。我说的是黛安·切斯特施内伯格。我挺喜欢那样的，因为那很明显是安吉拉在撒谎。
She won't say. She won't say, although she's very much self-consciously fidgeting with it. I wanted to tell you guys in the script it said that Angela's friend's name was Diane Chester Berg. And in one take I changed the last name. I said Diane Chester Schnenberg. And I liked that because it was clearly Angela Lying.
她很明显是想用黛安·切斯特施内伯格来掩盖德怀特·库尔特·施鲁特。我一直以来最喜欢的喜剧梗之一，就是当有人试图用一个假名字来为自己撒谎解围，却又编不圆的时候。我想这是因为我不擅长现场即兴发挥。每当我上即兴表演课，不得不说出我的角色名字时，
She was clearly trying to cover up Dwight Kurt Schrute with Diane Chester Schnigberg. One of my all-time favorite comedy things is when someone says a fakey name to try to lie their way out of something, and they can't. I think it's because I am not good at improv on the spot. And whenever I was in improv classes and I had to like say my character name,
总是那种很蠢的名字。从来都不聪明。总是乱七八糟的。噢，我们可以每个人轮流来一个吗？我们每个人都说一个假的角色名字好吗？好啊。我的肯定糟透了。好吧，谁先来？编一个假的角色名字？好啊。我的肯定糟透了。好吧，谁先来？编
it was always stupid like that. It was never clever. It was always just mangled. Oh, can we all go around and do one? Can we all say a fakey character name? Sure. Mine's gonna be awful. All right, who goes first? Make up a fakey character name? Sure. Mine's gonna be awful. All right, who goes first? Make
一个假的角色名字。萨姆，你来。史密瑟斯·克兰普顿。你答得太快了。谢谢。你是史密瑟斯·克兰普顿？挺不错的。我脑子里有这个角色的形象了。好吧。对，史密瑟斯和特德·邦格斯是朋友。特德·邦格斯。好吧。好的。我是贝茜·贝利·韦利。看吧？不，但就是这样。贝茜·贝利·韦利，但我说出来时，就像我一开始明明气势很足。那根本不是我在演段子。
up a fakey character name. Sam, go. Smithers Crampton. You did that so quickly. Thank you. You're Smithers Crampton? That's good. I like that character. I have an idea of him in my head. Okay. Yeah, Smithers is friends with Ted Bungus. Ted Bungus. Okay. All right. I am Betsy Belly Welly. See? No, but that's it. Betsy Belly Welly, but I say it, like I started off so strong. That was not even me doing a bit.
那是我在说一个名字的过程中真的慌了神。好吧，这就是——贝茜·贝利·韦利。这完全就是安吉拉·马丁干的事。这女人是谁？她，她，这绝对是表演课上的教学。安吉拉，到你了，来吧。蒂尔达·内尔斯。蒂尔达·内尔斯。
That was me really panicking in the middle of saying a name. Well, this is- Betsy Belly Welly. This is exactly what Angela Martin did. Who is this woman? She, she, that's exactly the acting lesson. Angela, what's yours go? Tilda Nells. Tilda Nells.
蒂尔达·内尔斯。好吧。好吧。我很想读一个剧本，一个短片。关于这四个角色的。那其实挺棒的。好吧，随着会计们你一言我一语地争论不休，凯文就说，我们必须停下来。
Tilda Nells. Okay. All right. I'd love to read a script, a short. Of those. Of those four characters. That would be great actually. Okay, well as the accountants just go back and forth at one another, Kevin's like, we have to stop this.
我们不能开始自相残杀。那才是偷钱的那家伙希望我们做的事。现在唯一能做的事就是调查迈克尔。然后镜头摇过去，我们看到迈克尔的办公桌前坐着一个人。是谁？不是史蒂夫。不是史蒂夫。我们将在下一集第八集《你的意思是》里看到这个人的很多镜头，我们收到了很多关于它的粉丝提问。所以他是谁？好吧，俄亥俄州阿克伦的艾梅莉亚·S说，我注意到
We can't start turning on one another. That's what the guy who sold the money would want us to do. The only thing left to do is to investigate Michael. And then the camera pans over and we see someone at Michael's desk. Who is it? It's not Steve. It's not Steve. And we're gonna see a lot of this person in the next episode number eight titled Your Mean and we got a lot of fan questions about it. So who is it? Well Amelia S from Akron, Ohio said, I noticed
所有迈克尔的镜头都是从远处的办公大区对面拍的。得克萨斯州凯蒂的贝基·K说，扮演迈克尔的演员是谁？我猜那不是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。好吧，各位，那是保罗·邦内尔扮演的替身演员。当然啦，安吉拉，你肯定知道那不是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，因为你在现场。没错。不过我喜欢它成功骗过观众的那个时刻。确实很有帮助。尽管，贝基确实说过，我觉得
all the shots of Michael are from across the bullpen far away. And Becky Kay from Katie, Texas said, who was the actor who played Michael? I assume it was not Steve Carell. Well, everyone, it was a photo double played by Paul Bunnell. And Angela, of course, you knew it wasn't Steve Carell because you were there. That's right. I love that it sold that moment though. It really helped. Although, Becky did say, I thought
迈克尔离开办公室时居然没有一场盛大的告别仪式这很奇怪，因为下一集网络短剧的开头就是从迈克尔离开开始的。对。这使得会计们有可能走进他的办公室开始东翻西找。但在他们走进迈克尔的办公室之前，他们有点像是在进行秘密监视。他们只是在等迈克尔离开。凯文说，几点啦？怎么他还没走？几点啦？安吉拉说，你为什么不自己看一眼时钟呢？
it was weird that Michael didn't have a big goodbye when he leaves the office, because the top of this next web episode is going to begin with Michael leaving. Right. And this makes it possible for the accountants to go into his office and start poking around. But before they go into Michael's office, they're kind of on a stakeout. They're just waiting for Michael to leave. Kevin says, what time is it? Like, why hasn't he gone? What time is it? And Angela says, why don't you check the clock for yourself?
然后他说，你直接告诉我几点不就好了吗？她就说，我觉得人应该自食其力。好吧，凯文觉得她很刻薄。这可把她给惹毛了。剧本上写着安吉拉在做杂务。然后凯文和奥斯卡进行了这样一段对话。奥斯卡要去商场，因为他需要一双新鞋。然后安吉拉突然脱口而出，你知道的，我一点也不刻薄。噢，女士，我有一段音频剪辑，
And he's like, why don't you just tell me what time it is? And she's like, I think people should be self-sufficient. Well, Kevin thinks she's mean. This really ruffles her feathers. In the script, it says Angela makes busy work. And then Kevin and Oscar sort of have this conversation. Oscar's going to the mall because he needs a new walk. And then Angela just blurts out, you know, I'm not mean. Oh, lady, I have an audio
因为不管出于什么原因，安吉拉要道歉了，她要说两次对不起，不是一次而是两次，我觉得我们必须听一下，因为我相当确信这是“对不起”这几个字唯一几次从安吉拉·马丁的嘴里说出来。如果我表现得不好，我很抱歉没关系，谢谢你那真让人尴尬那真让人尴尬。好吧，我们走吧。这太有趣了。
clip because for whatever reason Angela is going to apologize she's gonna say sorry twice not once but twice and I thought we had to hear it because I'm fairly certain these are the only times the words, I'm sorry come out of Angela Martin's mouth ever I'm sorry if I was me It's okay, thank you That was uncomfortable That was uncomfortable. Okay, let's go. This is so much fun.
这本来就不是为了好玩。再次抱歉。两个对不起。我知道。哇。我知道，我猜她真的很在意凯文觉得她刻薄不刻薄。在网络短剧里她确实在意。
It's not supposed to be fun. Again, sorry. Two sorrys. I know. Wow. I know, I guess she clearly cares about Kevin thinking if she's mean or not. In the webisodes she does.
至少在这个世界里是这样。但这并不能阻止她继续刻薄。好吧，当他们走向迈克尔的办公室时，凯文朝着迈克尔的办公室做了一个非常搞笑的某种舞蹈动作。剧本里写着，凯文做出吉姆·贝鲁西式的或者《动物屋》里潜入院长办公室的隐蔽动作。对，我当时没领会到那个梗。
At least in this world. But it's not going to stop her from being mean. Well, as they walk over to Michael's office, Kevin does this very funny sort of dance move towards Michael's office. In the script it says, Kevin does the Jim Belushi slash Animal House entering the dean's office stealth maneuver. Yes, it was lost on me.
至少在这个世界上是这样。但这并不能阻止她刻薄。好吧，当他们走向迈克尔的办公室时，凯文向迈克尔的办公室做了一个非常搞笑的某种舞蹈动作。剧本里写着，凯文做了一个类似于约翰·贝鲁什或《动物屋》里潜行进入院长办公室的动作。是的，我完全没看懂。
It's also lost on Angela and Oscar. Yes, in the script, it didn't give any stage direction for our reaction, but Oscar and I both just chose to be not impressed. And Brian improvised, you guys are breaking my spirit. All right, episode number nine, titled Michael's Office. They are in there.
安吉拉和奥斯卡也没有get到。是的，剧本里并没有给我们对这个反应的舞台指示，但我和奥斯卡都选择表现得不为所动。布莱恩即兴说了一句：你们俩在打击我的积极性。好吧，第九集，标题是《迈克尔的办公室》。他们就在里面。
They are looking through his stuff. This is my favorite one. This is your favorite? Yes, because we just were sort of just doing all of these silly bits. And you know, Kevin has the first line in the webisode, but it wasn't scripted for him to say it into Michael's toy megaphone.
他们在翻找他的东西。这是我最喜欢的一个。这是你最喜欢的？对，因为我们当时就是在瞎胡闹。你知道，凯文在网络剧中有了第一句台词，但剧本里并没有让他对着迈克尔的玩具扩音器说。
I thought that was so funny. Brian just did that, I loved it. He also added the attention. Yes, now the part where he picks up the train whistle and blows it, that was scripted? That was, yes. I love that Oscar points out the Seiko timepiece like certificate, I just loved that.
我觉得这太好笑了。布莱恩临时加的，我太喜欢了。他还加上了“注意”这个词。对，现在他拿起火车哨子吹的那一段，是按剧本来的吗？是的，是按剧本来的。我特别喜欢奥斯卡指出那个精工手表证书的细节，我太爱了。
Yes, and then something odd happens. They unlock a drawer in Michael's office and they find nine Dunder Mifflin snow globes. It's so interesting. Why? Like why? What are those for? I don't know.
对，然后发生了一件奇怪的事。他们打开了迈克尔办公室里的一个抽屉，发现了九个邓德米夫林的雪花球。这太有意思了。为什么？就像是，为什么？这些是用来干嘛的？我也不知道。
And Kevin says if he had a snow globe drawer, he'd keep it locked too. Yeah. Well, Oscar tells Angela to go online, look at Michael's quicken. I have a little thing to share about this. The scene was actually longer. Okay.
凯文说如果他也有一个放雪花球的抽屉，他也会锁起来。对。嗯，奥斯卡让安吉拉上网查查迈克尔的Quicken账单。我这里有个小花絮想分享一下。其实这个场景原本更长。好吧。
When Angela logged onto the computer, it started like this. Angela says, okay, I'm in. Ugh, gross. Oscar and Kevin look. Kevin says, oh my god. Oscar says, yikes. Kevin says, that guy must be like a hundred years old. Oscar says, what's he holding? Kevin says, I think it's a shovel. And then Oscar says, okay okay, go check his Quicken files. What in the world had come up on the computer? What was he
当安吉拉登录电脑时，开头是这样的。安吉拉说：好吧，我登上了。呃，真恶心。奥斯卡和凯文看过去。凯文说：哦天哪。奥斯卡说：哎哟。凯文说：这家伙得有一百岁了吧。奥斯卡说：他手里拿的是什么？凯文说：我觉得是一把铲子。然后奥斯卡说：行了行了，去查查他的Quicken文件。电脑上到底弹出了什么？他当时在
googling? I don't know. The last eight charges were from Jack's Joke and Magic Shop. He loves that place. Angela's gonna go ahead and pay his electric bill real quickly. This was my favorite thing that I did. It was so fun to me. And when Kevin's like, what are you doing? I'm like, I'm paying his electric, it's about to be shut off. Well, all of this snooping leads nowhere. They don't find anything. But Angela does pay some of Michael's bills.
搜索什么？我不知道。最后八笔消费都是在杰克斯笑话与魔术店花的。他超爱那个地方。安吉拉打算顺手帮他把电费交了。这是我干过最喜欢的事。我觉得太有意思了。当凯文问：你在干嘛呢？我说：我在帮他交电费，快要被停电了。好吧，这一通搜查根本没用。他们什么也没找到。不过安吉拉确实帮迈克尔交了些账单。
Yes. Well, we've made it now to the last one. It's episode 10 titled, The Best Day of My Life. It's gonna start with Angela and Dwight, they're whispering in the kitchen. I really feel like these scenes help the writers see Rain and Ice chemistry. Yes, I wanted to play the clip from the scene. Rain improvised a moment at the end. Let's see if you can guess. You're saying Michael stole money from his own company? Well, we've asked everyone else. No, no, that's insane. It has to be
对。好吧，现在我们来到最后一集了。第十集，标题是《我一生中最美好的一天》。开头是安吉拉和德怀特在厨房里窃窃私语。我真的觉得这些场景有助于编剧们看出雷恩和艾姬之间的化学反应。对，我想播放这个场景的片段。雷恩在结尾即兴发挥了一段。大家猜猜看。你说迈克尔偷了公司的钱？好吧，我们问过其他人了。不，不，这太疯狂了。一定得是
somebody else. Like Meredith. Her creed. No, Meredith, definitely. We asked her. She said she didn't do it. Which is exactly what you'd say if you did do it. Oh man, I should have been handling this investigation from the beginning. I believe she didn't do it. Are you doubting me? No And here Oh my god There has to be a better explanation How did he afford that new water bet he's always bragging about he charged it
别人。比如梅雷迪思。她的奎德。不，梅雷迪思肯定不是。我们问过她了。她说她没干。而这正是你干了之后会说的话。天哪，我应该从一开始就负责这个调查的。我相信她没干。你在怀疑我吗？不，而且在这里，天哪，肯定有更好的解释。他哪来的钱买他总挂在嘴边的新水床？他是刷卡买的。
Discover made a little cash back on the deal smart if you were a general And you accused him without proof I mean, I'm assuming it's the little bit about DVD if you want to come by later. You can't handle the truth. Just kidding. You can. I mean, I'm assuming it's the little bit about a few good men. It's just the very end when he says, you can't handle the truth. Just kidding. Yes, you can. I love early Dwight and Angela. It just is so fun to re-watch that. Well, now guess what? Mystery's about to be solved. Guess who it was. Guess who it was.
发现卡还给了一点现金返还，如果作为将军，你没有证据就指控他，这真的很聪明。我的意思是，我猜这有点像《义海雄风》的梗，如果你晚点来的话。你承受不了真相。开玩笑的。你可以。我是说，我猜这大概是《义海雄风》里的台词。就是最后他说“你承受不了真相。开玩笑的，其实你可以”。我太喜欢早期的德怀特和安吉拉了。重温这些真的太好玩了。好吧，现在猜怎么着？谜底要揭晓了。猜猜是谁干的。猜猜是谁干的。
From the very beginning, Jan said, I'm sure it's an accounting error. And Angela says, it is not an accounting error, at least not mine. Turns out it was. Turns out it was. She accidentally logged something twice. Yep. Yeah. Case closed. Yeah. Angela's like, oh well there you go. She is not
从一开始，简就说：我确信这是会计失误。安吉拉说：这不是会计失误，至少不是我的。结果还真是。结果还真是个失误。她不小心把某笔账记录了两次。 yep。好吧。案子破了。好吧。安吉拉就那种：好吧，那就这样呗。她才
gonna even for one moment admit that she really screwed up. She's back to business as usual, but Kevin is really having a moment here. He says this is the best day of my life. Yes Angela was wrong. Yeah. Angela did it. His face as Angela realizes it, the smile that comes over his face and Oscar too, they're gonna live off this moment for a long time. They sure are. All right well there you have it folks. The award winning webisodes, The Accountants. So fun. So fun, I would love to say thank you to Brian Baumgartner, Scott Kramer,
不会哪怕有一秒钟承认自己真的搞砸了。她又开始若无其事地工作了，但凯文此时真的很有戏。他说这是他这辈子最美好的一天。对，安吉拉错了。对。就是安吉拉干的。当安吉拉意识到这一点时，他脸上露出的笑容，奥斯卡也是，他们俩能靠这个梗回味好久呢。他们绝对会的。好啦，各位，这就是全部内容了。获奖网络剧《会计师》。太有意思了。太好玩了，我要感谢布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳、斯科特·克雷默、
Carol Angelo, and Joya Balfour. And I would like to throw out a thank you to Kentopedia, Kent Sbornak. It was so fun to be back in touch with him again. Yes, and I loved reconnecting with the NBC digital team. You know, everyone has moved on to different things, but they said they do have lots of fun stuff to share about future webisodes.
卡罗尔·安杰洛和乔伊娅·巴尔福尔。我还要感谢肯托百科（Kentopedia）的肯·斯博纳克。能再次和他取得联系真的太有趣了。对，我也很喜欢和NBC数字团队重新建立联系。你知道，大家都转向了不同的领域，但他们说有很多关于未来网络剧的有趣内容想要分享。
I hope we'll break down subtle sexuality. That one is pretty fun. So good. Mindy needs to come in. That would be so fun. She does. And thank you guys for sending in your questions and comments about the webisodes.
我希望我们能解析一下《微妙的性爱》（Subtle Sexuality）。那一集挺好玩的。太棒了。明迪应该来做客。那一定超级有趣。她真的应该来。谢谢大家发来关于网络剧的问题和评论。
I just love hearing everyone's perspective as they rewatch everything. Me too. Well, listen, join us next week for our second drink of healthcare, and then we're off next Wednesday for Thanksgiving. But we'll see you again the next week. Have a good one.
我特别喜欢听大家重温时的各种看法。我也是。好吧，听着，下周请加入我们，收听第二期的《医保》（Healthcare），然后下周三我们因感恩节休息。不过我们后周会再见。祝大家过得愉快。
See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到时候见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Audyssey呈现，詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。Audyssey的执行制片人是詹娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里夫·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。